look carefully in the ornate courtyard
of London's Royal Academy and you'll see
a tiny sculpture it's not about national
identity or heroics or idealized
sexuality its vulnerable and form
indestructible in iron it's based on the
artist six-day-old daughter placed
directly on the courtyard in this very
grand architectural setting and I think
the contrast of those two images really
asks us to question our place and our
relationship to the planet in the future
inside the show Gormley has further
disrupted the 150 year old gallery a
continuous 8 kilometre hollow tube of
aluminium is energetic the wild orbits
reflect Gormley's interest in physics
and subatomic paths English clay and
Atlantic sea water to a depth of 23
centimeters it's a marriage of the most
basic elements is it a destructive flood
or a primordial soup spawning life an
optical maze of steel mesh holds avoided
its core the center is the average size
of a modern bedroom the outdoor works by
Gormley are better known and thrive on
the ground scale only found in nature
the massive Angel of the North
stands 450 kilometres north of London
atop land where miners worked
underground in the dark
total darkness in the Royal Academy
visitors walk through the cave
reflecting the artists belief that with
closed eyes we are better able to
understand ourselves in this world of
constant distractions Gormley's works
bring a stillness and a silence it's art
stripped down to bare life the art feeds
on observation it demands personal
interpretation making people more aware
aware of the space they take up in the
world and where they stand in it
Jessica Baldwin al-jazeera London